it's the worst-hit city in Brazil with
the enormous favelas of Sao Paulo the
epicenter of the kovat 19 pandemic it's
taking the lives of at least a thousand
people a day in this country and if it's
not much worse than that already it's
likely to become so very soon the slums
are home to millions millions who live
with poverty disease and crime at the
best of times but these are the worst
we were taken inside the favelas by a
motor bike gang there are security we
couldn't move without them they call
themselves the cartel gang working the
streets of East South Paulo to have the
worst infection rates in the city
these Hells Angels are not a criminal
gang in the absence of effective state
aid they're bringing food and teaching
people how to stay clean and to stay
alive here they are indeed angellist
listen momento oh poor vision a
difficult most ambitious agreement
process for meters its own any silver
blade itaku no Gandalf a military
process mezzo Moorhead a Kelly Jagan
Oscar okay
defeating thing there is no the way I
think through all the bust and cheese
but then think about it
they want me for our size combat little
shaky news like each Illinois focused on
food each live one papycha mice mice
hustle now keep a special okay the
national government in particular the
country's president Jeb Olson are Oh
doubts the severity of kovat nineteen
but here they're living in fear
communities are closing their streets to
outsiders only residents are allowed in
[Music]
after a long period of national denial
and the fear of stigma the poorest
realized they're the most likely to die
from this pandemic they're trying to
teach each other how to survive this is
north-south paola it has the highest
death rates in the city ponies when
coded nineteen hits communities like
this one there's absolutely no
protection at all there's no medical
facilities anywhere the sewage in the
street
people live in basically cardboard
wooden houses it's quiet
because actually beside the government
inability to effectively bring about
nationwide goes down these people have
closed themselves there they still
working of course they have to everyone
here is expecting the hole coded 19
crises to go on and on many live in fear
refusing to open the metal gate to her
Shack Ruth leet is self isolating she's
already been ill in hospital and she's
still poorly she's moved here from her
previous street 22 neighbors died from
she's terrified of the disease
interpreting so across the country
people blame president balsa Naro for
his confusing messages and denial even
the United States a close ally has
closed its borders to Brazilians but the
confusion continues and the numbers of
people dying continues to rise mr.
Ramsay Sky News Sao Paulo